(traffic noises)
- Hi.
- I'm Emily.
- How are you, Emily?
- Nice to meet you.
Sorry, I know you're like so busy.
- Don't worry. How are you?
- I'm good.
How are you?
- Good.
- Okay, so I have a question for you.
- Okay, great.
- Okay, my first question.
Do you think we find our purpose,
or do you think our purpose finds us?
- We're going that philosophical, huh?
- That's what I'm about.
- I think our purpose finds us.
I feel like things come to me.
I think one could argue
that I'm doing the behavior
that allows that to happen.
But for some reason, I
believe that you're chosen
a little bit, 'cause I believe
a little bit more in DNA
than I think most people.
- Okay.
So like I'm gonna be a senior at Penn C,
so I'm trying to figure out
my big moves after graduation.
If you don't exactly
know what your passion is
in like a physical sense
of something, you know,
like creating business
ideas or things like that,
I'm more, like my
passion is people, so ...
- Yeah, I mean, look, I think
that there's a lot of people
who don't even know that it's
people, you know what I mean?
- [Emily] Yeah.
- So I think you're ahead of the game.
We're living a time right
now where so many people
of your age think that they
have to have a business
or it's cool to have a business.
Like there's no fucking
22 year old talking about
having a business 15 years ago.
- [Emily] Right.
- So you have to recognize
that that's just a conversation
of the moment.
I'm going to give you a
really good piece of advice
of this very short period of time.
- [Emily] Please.
Be binary about your decisions.
Let me tell you what I mean by that.
Don't overthink jumping
into your first job
and then quit it the next
day of it doesn't feel right.
It's not a end all, be all,
if the first one's not right.
- [Emily] That's the biggest thing.
- Nobody's gonna give a fuck
if you've got four companies
on your resume in the first two years.
No place you want to end up.
- [Emily] Yeah.
No, I totally get that.
- Well then, if you do,
you would stop thinking
about this completely.
- Overthinking is the rule.
It's definitely a thing.
- So either you get it or you don't.
- Yeah.
- So when you say I get
that, like I actually
want to have that conversation
because if you do get that,
you're about to get really
happy and real care-free.
If you don't get that, you
need to keep chipping away
to believe it.
- Yeah, I want to get that,
just because right now
my thing is like the unknown is so scary.
I'm about to graduate college
this year, like that's huge,
so the unknown is definitely
like a scary thing.
- It's fucking life.
- [Emily] Yeah.
- Like nobody knows what the
fuck's gonna happen tomorrow.
- So how do you, and I'm sorry ...
- It's alright, go ahead.
- How do you deal with the unknown?
Like when it comes to ...
- By recognizing that I
have no fucking choice.
- [Emily] Okay.
- Right.
- [Emily] Yeah.
- Like 'cause that's actually life,
like zero people exist.
- [Emily] Are you scared?
Like do you ever have
a fear of the unknown?
- Nope.
- How? Like that's what my main thing is,
like with every aspect.
- [Male] Because I'm confident.
- Yeah.
Totally.
- I'm not scared because I
know I can handle anything.
- [Emily] That's awesome.
- And I know I can handle anything because
I'm grateful for everything
I've got and I never envy
and want anything else.
I'm an optimist, like if
something bad happens tomorrow,
I would be fault into
thinking well I'm so grateful
that I've had it for this long,
instead of why did it go away?
- It's all about the
way you think about it.
- [Male] 100% and you
need to chip away at that.
And you need to realize
what's practical and not.
- I know.
That's like definitely
my moves and I'm learning
so much this summer, like
this internship is so great.
I've met a lot of people,
like I like to network,
I like to talk to people and
like everyone is just like,
you know if you want to talk
about whatever for 15 minutes
in the kitchen, everyone
is so willing to do that
and that's so refreshing and it's so,
it makes you feel so much
better about your future
because the more I talk
to people, the more
I hear that everybody
just had no idea what
they were doing when they were
my age and it all works out.
- 100%.
- [Emily] And that's so reassuring.
- That makes me happy.
- It makes me happy, thank you for that,
but that's awesome.
So I really, really appreciate that.
- [Male] You're welcome.
- The advice and yeah.
- [Male] Awesome, I'll see you soon.
I'm doing a group chat with you guys soon.
- [Emily] Yeah, Monday.
- [Male] Oh, Monday.
- [Emily] Are you going to
Singapore or did I make that up?
- [Male] That's in October.
- [Emily] That's October?
- [Male] Have a great weekend, take care.
- [Emily] You too.